[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello,
I'm Dustin Kirkland,
product manager at
Google and your host
at KubeCon Copenhagen. I'm
joined here by Khash Sajadi.
He's the CEO and
founder of Cloud 66,
and he's going to tell us
a little bit about his path
to Kubernetes.
KHASH SAJADI: Sure.
Thank you.
So we are a SAS company.
We deliver developmental
tools for software companies.
And as a result of
being a SAS company,
we were hosting our
applications for the past four
and half years on AWS, CC2--
a normal setup of a cloud setup.
And as part of our
products, we were
building Kubernetes
clusters for our customers
to deploy their applications.
Ultimately, the rigidity of
including and introducing
new infrastructure components
to our own infrastructure setup
that runs Cloud 66 SAS led
us to move over to running
Kubernetes ourselves.
While we consider ourselves
experts in Kubernetes,
and we build that
for our customers,
we wanted to decouple
the risk and not
have too much of an
inception, if you will.
So we moved to the
best Kubernetes
that we could find
outside of Cloud 66,
and that was Google GKE.
So the migration planning for
us took about three to four
months, and most of it was spent
around risk mitigation and data
transfer planning for
our customers to have--
we have customers in
about 120 countries.
So there's no night time.
There's no downtime.
We had to do that in a seamless
way as much as possible.
And then the migration
itself took a day.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Wow.
KHASH SAJADI: So we
planned the whole thing
and we did the entire
thing in a day.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So three
to four months planning,
a day to do the migration?
KHASH SAJADI: Yes.
So our move to GKE was smooth.
As a result, it cut our
infrastructure costs
by about 60%.
But I think the best
takeaway that we took away
from moving to Kubernetes,
and GKE in this instance,
was it added to the agility of
our production and operations
team.
We wanted to be
able to introduce
new components and
joint infrastructure,
like search components.
And we didn't want
to learn maintenance
of yet another product, or
having to go and outsource
that from third-party
vendors all around,
making us more
dependent on a variety
of different components.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Now,
that 60% cost savings
on the infrastructure,
is that primarily savings
on the management layer?
KHASH SAJADI: There is a part
that's not very tangible,
and that's how much
time we spend less
on managing infrastructure,
which is on another P&L.
Which I wouldn't
know much about.
I don't have that much
visibility over it,
because it's kind of
funny money in a way.
But when it comes
to spend, we now
tend to spin up bigger
boxes, as in VMs,
and pack them much
more efficiently.
Before we had one component
that would take over
the entire server but
would be utilized at 20%.
Now we can move workloads around
and make it more flexible.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
OK.
So Kubernetes has
helped Cloud 66.
Tell me a little bit
about Cloud 66's business.
What do you guys
do with Kubernetes?
KHASH SAJADI: So our SAS
product-- we have two products.
One is scaffolding and
building Kubernetes clusters
for our customers, but our
focus is not doing that.
As building the container
side of the story,
we are mostly
focused on workloads
that you don't run inside of
the containers, like database
backups, replication, firewall,
audit management, access
to service.
That's called Cloud 66 Maestro.
And we actually built a
product out of our experience
of moving to Kubernetes and
managing our deployments
through Kubernetes, which
we call Cloud 66 Skycap
or container delivery pipeline.
We had to make sure two
things happen before we
can move to Kubernetes.
One is the technical
engineering side of it,
which you have one application.
You usually break it
apart into microservices,
and then you wrap
them into containers,
and you write a bunch
of configuration
files for Kubernetes to run.
That part is the easy part.
As an engineering team, we are
fairly capable of doing that.
The part that we had to
make sure that happens
is, do we have the
toolset to change
the mentality of the team that
not the entire application goes
out at the same time?
Somethings are
dependent on other ones
when the deployment happens.
How do we know that
now that we have
two version controls,
essentially, one Git and one
Docker registry, for example,
we can trace and track things
down?
We can track and
trace things down
in terms of the
assets that are now
broken apart into hundreds of
containers of micro services.
How can we take care
of security secrets
and also make sure that our
IP is not linked into one
of the layers of Docker image?
All of that leading in to
actually building a product out
of that experience.
We are a product company,
and we provide that as a SAS
or offering to our customers.
So we took that opportunity
and productized our learnings.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Now,
application development
on Kubernetes takes a bit
of a different approach.
What did you learn on that
aspect of your journey,
on your road to Kubernetes?
KHASH SAJADI: That's
a very good question.
So in previous life, I've
worked as a software architect
for larger enterprises,
mostly investment banks,
and what I've experienced
was very, very, similar
to the experience that I
had with Martin Fowler's way
of doing microservices and
service-oriented architecture,
if you will, based on contracts.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be broken up
into multiple services.
But we found that applying
those principles when
it comes to
contract-based development
and having a definitive
internal API between services
always helps, regardless
of whether that codebase is
one codebase or
you break it up out
into physical
different codebases.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Great.
So I understand that we've
got a bit of a demo here?
KHASH SAJADI: Yes
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: All
right, let's see it.
KHASH SAJADI: Great.
OK, so we have, as part
of Cloud 66 Skycap,
which is container delivery
pipeline into Kubernetes,
an application that is
just one simple service,
and I wanted to
deploy that to GKE.
So here's what we do.
We have a concept
of a formation.
And formation for us is
a deployment destination.
It's like, environments
don't have it anymore,
because you might have five
productions and 12 stagings
just because you can do
that based on a Kubernetes
namespace.
We do that.
And here, I'm adding different
parts of the application
based on templates--
Kubernetes native templates--
that we have in a Git
repository.
The idea for us was to not
wrap the Kubernetes API
into yet another API.
To just control the access
of our team to Kubernetes,
we wanted developers
to have the full access
and experience the full
benefits of Kubernetes
when it comes to templates.
But also, for the ops
teams and ops people
to have a say over how
things are deployed.
So here I'm setting up a
namespace from my Kubernetes
information.
And here, I'm doing a
deployment of a service.
So this is a normal
Kubernetes deployment asset,
as you can see.
And the idea is that my
ops team will dictate,
if you want to deploy or add
a deployment to Kubernetes,
how should it look like.
For example, if
you're running on GKE,
you might want to run
on Cloud SQL as well,
and therefore you
need cloud proxy
as a side car for
production, but this is not
a concern for staging.
Therefore, my ops
guys can dictate that,
I'm going to add the
port for my service,
enter to the command that
starts it in a normal Kubernetes
or Docker-friendly way.
In this instance, I'm
running RADIUS directly here
as a container.
And this is all backed
by a Git repository,
so you can use normal Git flow
as opposed to using the web UI.
And the last step for this
is to create a service that
represents that deployment.
Again, this is more ops
teams' opinion on how
the service should look like.
And this comes from a
Git repository itself,
so you can evolve this.
Here, because I'm deploying to
GKE, instead of a node balance
I'm using a load balance there.
So GKE will fire that up
for me and save the changes.
And because we were
running RADIUS,
we are going to run RADIUS
inside of my cluster as well.
I'm going to just
fire up RADIUS.
Now, this could be a Helm
chart that I can get off
the shelf and just
deploy RADIUS,
or it could be my team's
opinion on how RADIUS should
be deployed in my organization.
And once I have all those
components, what happens
is what we call taking a
snapshot of your application,
which will take
a snapshot of all
your codebase, all
pre-built images
that you have for
your application,
and then all of
those will result
in a rendered set of Kubernetes
native configuration files
that you can then
apply to your cluster.
I'm just going to
get the command that
will generate that.
We do support
multi-accounts, so I'm just
going to switch it
to our demo account,
and then paint that
onto a Kube control
and apply it to
my cluster, which
is the GKE Cluster that I have.
So the namespace--
the secret, which
would be the Docker registry
that we provide, all of that
is going to get created.
The namespace is there now.
And let's check the pods.
Great.
So the pods are running.
And I'm going to
just quickly check
the service to make sure
to look balancer is up.
OK.
So the IP address is
now getting started.
I'm going to just
put a watch on it.
It's up now.
OK.
So I'm just going to get the
IP address that GKE gave me,
and there we are.
So my app is up and running.
But most importantly-- this
was a simple app, obviously.
But this is based on the
opinion that my operations guys
want me to have.
And I can then
switch this formation
into another
deployment target that
is running a homemade
Kubernetes cluster that
doesn't require certain things.
Or my ops guys can
force my developers
to every time they add a
new deployment, for example,
they need to have a sidecar
for log shipping, for example.
So it gives you the
flexibility of a Kubernetes API
without the risks of being
able to change things
in the entire cluster that
you're not supposed to.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
That's super interesting.
I can see how this would
drastically improve and speed
up some development cycles.
All right, Khash, thank you
very much for your time.
Cheers
[MUSIC PLAYING]